Hey guys, Pete here. This will be my Dark (Netflix)
season 3 official trailer breakdown. It
dropped today and it's packed with new
stuff that's got me really excited.
There's so much in this I'm just gonna
do a scene-by-scene breakdown, and then
in a couple of days I'll follow up with
another video going a little deeper into
what it all might mean. So make sure you
chime in with your ideas in the comments
and subscribe to the channel so you
won't miss that.
Of course this video will contain
spoilers if you're not caught up through
the end of season 2, or you don't like
trailers and speculation this is your
chance to leave. the trailer opens with
the closing scene of alt Martha saving
Jonas from the apocalypse in season 2. we
see Jonas opening his eyes and then
walking away from the cave with the red
and white tape across it. In the
voice-over we hear Martha say, "I'll help
you find the origin. the one thing. the
beginning for everything in your world
and in mine." this is over a collection of
shots that include Jonas in the woods of
the alt world, stranger Jonas looking at
the letter from Martha that he's holding
in his hands, and a display of names -
sort of a family tree that mirrors
itself with an infinity symbol in the
middle. we can't see all of it but it
looks like this is how the two worlds
are connected and we'll see where this
is at later in the trailer. when we
actually see Martha talking she looks
like she did in the second teaser when
she was in 1888 where Stranger was
building the time machine under the
church. it then cuts to her traveling
with the orb and this time she looks
like she's dressed of that time period.
the voice-over continues, "today is the
day everything began in your world and mine
from a knot that's intertwined."
while she's talking there's an aerial
shot, a shot of the forest
post-apocalypse, and then a split screen
of Jonas and Martha both waking up in
their respective beds in their
respective worlds inside the Kahnwald
house. there's a quick shot of someone
drawing the knot in dust and then
Elisabeth holding the watch
post-apocalypse.
this ties into the photo that was
released preseason showing the response
to the power plant accident which will
actually see later in this
trailer. after that there's a shot of a
desk with the watch on it, a copy of the
play Ariadne that Martha was in in season
one and a black leather bound book
that's new to me. this appears to be the
alt world equivalent to Adam's lair
under the church which I'm going to
think of as Eve's lair until I'm proven
wrong. the voiceover changes to this
older woman's voice saying everything
repeats itself as none of us are
prepared to let go. this almost has to be
Eve's voice since it doesn't sound like
any of the known characters from
previous seasons and it's very similar
to something that Adam would say. the new
trio of characters are standing in front
of her desk although we can't tell if
the voice-over is from that same scene.
something that stands out here is that
their lips scars are on the right side
of their faces when we see them in the
alt world in this trailer. I noticed that
it was reversed from the date
announcement teaser but I'm not sure
what that means for the big picture. when
it cuts away from them we get splitscreen shots of characters and their alts.
we see Katharina who in the alt world has
glasses and bangs, young Elisabeth that
has pigtail braids, and Ulrich who has
darker hair. there's a quick shot of
Jonas watching prime Martha die again
and then we cut back to the 19th century.
there's several people in this shot but
we only see them from behind. we notice
alt Martha and can tell because we saw
her in these clothes earlier and we can
assume that Stranger Jonas is the one
who is controlling things at the control
panel. the rest of them are sic mundus
members. it could definitely be Magnus
Franziska and Bartosz but we can't see
their faces. there's a bowl or a mortar
on a table in the center of the room. the
device is creating energy that looks
like lightning which is directed to a
substance inside the bowl. it breaks
apart and it looks similar to the dark
matter blobs from the advanced time
machines. since this is the area where
the god particle twin machine will be it
seems like a good bet that this is all
part of the process of creating it. then
we see older Elizabeth at the power
plant wearing a radiation suit her
mother / daughter Charlotte is behind
her which is very interesting and it
could mean that they were
brought together when they touched hands
through the wormhole during the
apocalypse. they look to be looking at
the god particle inside the power plant
but we can't say for sure when they are.
That cuts to the trio who are looking at a
black blob in a place that looks
brand-new.
this is probably in the alt world but
where exactly or when they are is
anybody's guess. after that we get our
first glimpse of a cave that doesn't
have the forest around it. Martha turns to
look back as Jonas is going inside and
we'll revisit this in a little bit. after
that we get a couple more shots of
Winden prime after the apocalypse.
there's a hooded figure looking out from
behind a truck who I think might be
young Noah but it could also be Peter.
those are the two males that were inside
the bunker so I think it's probably one
of them. we see that shot of the
responders with barricades and they're
setting up the containment zone. this is
probably 2020 or sometime not long after
the apocalypse happened. we hear Jonas
say why am I here in the voice over and
then it cuts to a different woman's
voice who says this apocalypse also
happens in our world. the voice is
familiar and I think it's Charlotte but
I can't say for sure. as she's talking we
see alt Martha wearing the yellow
raincoat riding her bike towards the
power plant. we see that the background
is flipped in other words the
smokestacks are on the opposite side of
the frame. this is a visual clue that
we're in the alt world. then we see Adam
walking into the place where we saw the
trio and their god particle machine. in
the voiceover we hear Martha say you
believe all this that they'll all die
and we see what is probably Peter
burying a body post-apocalypse. possibly
he's burying Marta's body here. we then
see a close-up of his face with a grown
out beard and see that he's looking at a
wall of photos. I'm guessing that these
are photos of all the bodies that were
recovered after the event. the only one I
could recognize was Justyna who worked
at the police station and whose grave we
saw in 2053 back in the beginning of
season 2. Jonas says it must never happen
and we watch him crawling through the
passage in the caves. martha responds
with the question if there can only be
one world?
and we could see that they're talking
together outside of the cave. that cuts
to the older woman's voice saying a
world without you that's what you always
wanted as we see the sequence of the god
particle spinning and collapsing from
the first trailer. there's a title that
goes across the screen that says the
third cycle and then changes to the
final cycle. we see the trio and Adam's
lair again and here Martha say you
promised there would be a way to change
it all. that cuts to a sequence of people
getting bludgeoned. the first looks like
young Elisabeth to me based on the hair
but you can't say for sure and I don't
know where they're at then we see the
same scene with Helene Albers by the
lake from the first trailer and then
finally alt Ulrich who is probably
beating alt Helge. then we see Jonas and
Martha coming out into the desolation
surrounding the cave. we hear Adam
saying we can't escape our fate and then
a masked woman approaches them from the
wasteland.
I have no idea who this is my best guess
is that it could be Claudia just because
we don't see or anywhere else in this
trailer and it definitely looks like a
woman. after that we see Jonas yelling
what do you want from me
at Adam in the Kahnwald house then we
see a shot of the Trinity knot notebook
with the entry about the final cycle
before we get a shot of adult Noah he
looks like he's under the church he's
not wearing the priest suit and we can't
tell for sure but this is probably alt
Noah or maybe he goes by Hanno in this
world if Eve didn't change his name
he has older-looking clothing but that's
all we see then we see Jonas turn as Eve
says I want your journey to finally come
to an end this makes it sound like her
motivation may be for Adam to sacrifice
himself and maybe she thinks that he is
the starting point that cuts to a
mirrored image of two hands turning a
dial of some sort one hand looks like a
young man's and the other looks older
this has the feeling that it's the same
person doing the same thing at a
different period of time next we see the
god particle spinning again which
starts a series of images we see Adam
watching what's happening at the power
plant then we get a look at alt
Aleksander and alt Charlotte probably
setting off the
apocalypse in the alt world this might
be connected to the voice-over earlier
that I thought was Charlotte the red
radiation suits definitely mark this
as the alt world and we could see the
dark matter rising up from the barrels
then there is a shot of the passage with
this column of light inside it this
looks similar to what was going on when
Katarina was looking through the door
during the apocalypse but can't tell for
sure what's going on here we hear Jonas
yells Martha while we see a shot of her in
the mouth of the cave. then there is this
shot that looks like Michael's painting
studio but it's a bedroom in the alt
world it's hard to make out who's in the
shot for certain but I'm guessing it's
alt Marta and alt Katarina
that cuts to the shot of the god
particle from below splitting open and
we hear Martha yell Jonas as she's saying
that it looks like a hooded stranger is
getting hit with the electricity and I
have a feeling this is where Adam got
his scars you know this is where the
stranger turned into Adam there's an
outside possibility that this could be
younger Jonas since he's wearing the
hood and we can't see it but I don't
know why he would be back in time this
looks like it's going on pre 1921 if I
had to guess then we see Martha running
in the desert landscape with Jona
following behind they're coming out of
the bunker which makes me think that all
of these scenes take place in the far
future rather than like say in the past
although this could just be what the
alt-world looks like after their
apocalypse so I'm not sure then we see
this crazy-looking shot of alt Magnus
and alt Franziska sitting by the lake
just watching the apocalypse happen they
look quite content to have their lives
end right there in that moment right
after that we see alt Marta standing in
front of alt Bartosz who has a bike we
see Jonas come in out of the frame to
grab a hold of her when I first saw this
I thought they were getting taken out by
the apocalypse like Magnus and Franziska
but when you slow it down you can see
the golden light and realize that he's
grabbing her to travel essentially he's
doing for her what she did for him in
his world but in a more dramatic fashion
then we see Eve and the trio in her lair we
see the names from earlier there on the
floor in front of the painting and we
hear her say and thus the cycle repeats
itself
her white hair and this image had some
people thinking that this might be
Claudia but the voiceover doesn't seem
to support that I think this is probably
Eve I think it's probably an aged up
Martha and nothing in this trailer really
contradicted that for me then the
trailer ends with the reverse shot of
Jonas and Martha kissing in front of the
caves and it ends in a similar way to
the original teaser we here at Helge and
the voice-over saying tick-tock we see
that the apocalypse is coming and the
release date 6/27/2020 since the video is
already getting long just a couple of
things Agnes is the character who is
connected to the infinity sign in Eve's
family tree display that makes it look
like the symbol is Tronte's father so
not sure what to make of that yet a
simple explanation would be that the
infinity symbol represents that these
two worlds are trapped in an infinite
knot and based on some of the voiceover
it sounds like Martha believes they can
find a source. if there actually is a
source then perhaps there's something
different going on here like neither one
of these worlds is the prime world. it's
interesting because that belief may not
be one that she holds when she grows
older to become Eve I imagine that Eve
has her plan similar to how Adam has his
and there's no reason to believe that
her relationship to Marta wouldn't be
similar to Adam And Jonas I can't tell if
Adam and Eve are working together or how
the trio fits into the bigger picture it
almost seems like they're her version of
sic Mundus but they're only one
person and not a group and I don't think
anything is clear.
if you're wondering about Hanno Tauber
that name is Noah's we learned that
earlier in relation to the church but
thought that might be an alias he used
there's a lot in this trailer that's new
but it doesn't really give away the game
too much and there's a ton of stuff that
we don't see at all like I said we don't
really see Claudia we just get really
short glimpses of the alt world and what
might be going on there we can see that
we're going to be visiting all these
different time periods so it's exciting
and it's crazy when I think about how
much time I spend thinking about this
show making videos
this show and really I don't know what's
going to happen it's pretty cool and
with that I will leave this there please
tell me in the comments about anything I
might have missed anything you caught
anything you might think is different
from what I thought let me know what
your theories are after watching this
like I said I will come out with another
video in the next couple of days where I
look more closely at what's happening
and what I think it all means please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon